hey there I'm Chris Pine I'm on the set
of the new Armani code commercial
welcome it's a very short piece so it
really just required setting the
boundaries in the context of what this
little mini story was and then showing
up and having a bunch of people put
makeup on and dress being fine clothes
world of modelling fascinates me to no
end and is not for me because with
acting at least you have the barrier of
lines and words and a character so
inevitably because you're on the screen
people are nitpicking and picking apart
how you look and all that but to think
that there as a model that's you know
oftentimes people are just looking about
how fat or skinny or I just could deal
with it I don't have thick enough skin
quite honestly well I love it I mean now
it's my second or third year with the
Armani folks and I I really get along
with all of them and have developed you
know a nice friendly off out of business
parameters relationships with these
people so I've had a great time I love
the creativity of it it's a very fast
very quick process and right now I'm
filming a movie so to come in I just
have to switch gears and throw myself
into it and thank God we have a great
director and a great director of
photography and a wonderful creative
team behind it
you